you need to get tougher on social issues
there was actually some good news last
night
out of kenosha wisconsin in kenosha
wisconsin
the district attorney announced that
none of the police officers
involved in the jacob blake shooting
case will face charges take a listen to
the
d.a
it is my decision now that i announced
today before you
that no kenosha law enforcement officer
in this case
will be charged with any criminal
offense based on the facts and the laws
as i will describe them to you now so it
is our decision that no charge will be
filed
i'm going to also tell you just because
i think it is important
that i that no charge will be filed
against jacob blake
in regards to this incident as well that
for many of the same reasons uh in terms
of
overall discussion about this case that
is not
something that is something that the
district attorney's office intends to
pursue the left is furious
lots of activist groups are coming on
saying this is a terrible miscarriage of
justice
there is a miscarriage of justice here
the miscarriage of justice is that jacob
blake will not be charged for the crimes
he was committing at the time
it's a very good thing that the cops are
not being charged there was absolutely
zero reason why the cops should be
charged if you remember that case
the a woman calls the cops to
her house because this guy jacob blake
allegedly
came in sexually assaulted her it was
true it was a
bad guy who was trying to take her kids
uh he already had a warrant out
uh he then the cops told him hey stop
moving stop what you're doing he
wouldn't stop he kept walking to his car
they tased him he kept moving they tased
him again he kept moving he then goes to
his car reaches for a knife
and only at that point do the cops shoot
him and we were told this is awful he's
an unarmed
unarmed black man he's this is a raci
racist killing
nothing of the sort so it yeah it would
be good if jacob blake were charged and
prosecuted
he won't be politically i understand why
he won't be
the mainstream media are outright lying
about this the washington post tweeted
out quote
police officers won't be charged in
shooting of jacob blake an unarmed black
man who was shot seven times in the back
in kenosha wisconsin
d.a says the trouble with the unarmed
black man theory is the guy
had a knife very important
jacob blake while actively resisting
arms himself with a knife
i continue to hear i think i heard it
the rally last night
the vigil where someone again said he
was unarmed
it is absolutely incontrovertible that
jacob lake was armed with a knife during
this encounter
absolutely incontrovertible that jacob
blake was armed with a knife but it
doesn't seem to matter
and this is something that the left does
all the time
first of all you probably didn't even
hear that fact because the media had
been covering it up and
and a lot of them are not even covering
that presser but
it doesn't matter whenever the left
constructs a narrative jacob blake's an
unarmed black man
innocent he was killed by theirs they
were shot by the cops then the facts
come out and contradict that
and they say well okay whatever about
the facts in this case
it gets to a greater truth the lie that
we're telling gets to a greater truth
they are so
taken with their own abstract theories
they're so taken with their own ideology
that they will not let reality
get in the way of that and i think a lot
of squishy republicans think oh gosh
they must have a point there must be
something to this whole thing
uh there they must maybe if we try to be
a little conciliatory and me in the
middle there's no meeting in the middle
these guys are peddling lies and their
lies designed to
upend law and order in this country and
up injustice in this country
and you got to get tough on it that is
some at least a little bit of good news
out of kenosha even as we have to deal
with this very bad news
out of georgia and out of the senate i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you